nos piden resolver para p y tenemos la
siguiente desigualdad menos 3 p menos 7
menor que p más 9 ok entonces lo que
esencialmente nos piden hacer es
despejar la p y lo que casi siempre se
hace es despejar la del lado izquierdo
yo creo que es más sencillo verlo de
esta forma y
es lo que vamos a hacer entonces vamos
lo primero que se me ocurre es por
ejemplo restar pe para poder quitar esta
que está del lado derecho entonces lo
que vamos a hacer es restar pe y para
que la desigualdad no se vea afectada lo
que tenemos que hacer es restar de ambos
lados y es decir pues para que no haya
problemas con el signo en la desigualdad
lo que restamos de un lado es lo que
restamos del otro ok y entonces
resolvemos para esto del lado izquierdo
nos queda menos 3 p - p que son menos 4
p y el menos 7 pues se queda igual y
esto es menor que p - p que se cancelan
y solo me quedan 9 muy bien entonces lo
que hice fue restar p de ambos lados
para que para que la desigualdad se siga
conservando muy bien entonces ahora lo
siguiente que a mí se me ocurre es
quitar este menos 7 de aquí pues sumando
7 de ambos lados entonces ahora sumamos
7 de ambos lados y que es lo que me
queda del lado izquierdo pues estos se
cancelan y solo me queda
24 p que es menor que 9 + 7 que son 16
muy bien entonces ahora ya lo que
tenemos es que menos 4 p se relaciona
con 16 y para poder quitar este menos 4
que ya lo único que nos está estorbando
con la p pues podemos dividir entre
menos 4 verdad de ambos lados y no he
puesto la desigualdad porque justamente
hay que recordar que cuando uno
multiplica o divide por algún número
negativo la desigualdad se invierte
cambia de dirección entonces ahora en
vez de ser menor que va a ser un mayor
que muy bien entonces del lado izquierdo
lo que tenemos es que estos se cancelan
y simplemente me queda p mayor que 16
entre menos 4 que es menos 4 y esta ya
es mi solución del problema bueno esto
me da el conjunto de valores de p que
son solución o que satisfacen esta
desigualdad
si pudiéramos graficar lo por ejemplo
ponemos aquí nuestra recta numérica más
o menos así entonces pues digamos que
por aquí anda al menos 5 menos 4 - 3
2 - 1 el 0 el 1 y así ok entonces lo que
nos dice esto es que nos tomamos todos
los valores más grandes que menos 4 sin
incluir a menos 4 entonces le ponemos
una bolita abierta y nos tomamos todos
los que están a su derecha que son los
que son más grandes y entonces aquí ya
tenemos graficado nuestro conjunto
solución de esta desigualdad ahora sólo
para sentirnos bien y sentirnos cómodos
vamos a intentar algunos valores para
ver que esto si se cumple por ejemplo
qué pasa si nos tomamos aquí el menos 3
pues el menos 3 si está en el conjunto
solución así que debe satisfacer esta
desigualdad por ejemplo qué pasaría si
ponemos en vez de pepe ponemos menos
tres menos tres aquí entonces es menos
tres por peques menos tres menos 7
debería ser menor que menos 3 más 9
vamos a comprobarlo menos 3 por menos 3
9 menos 7 es menor que 9 menos 3 que es
y 9 menos 72 que es menor que 6 y
claramente si funciona este ejemplo
vamos a tomarnos ahora uno que no está
en el conjunto solución digamos este
menos 5 entonces hacemos lo mismo en vez
de ponemos menos 5 y entonces nos quedan
menos 3 por p qué es menos 5 menos 7 es
menor que menos 59 ok esto es la
desigualdad que queremos ver si es
cierta uno cuantos menos tres x menos
cinco pues esto es 15 menos 7 debe ser
menor que 9 menos 5 que es 4 y 15 menos
7 son 8 que claramente no es menor que 4
entonces éste no funcionó y qué bueno
que no funciona porque no habíamos
incluido o el menos 5 no está incluido a
nuestro en nuestro conjunto solución ok
entonces sólo como un último intento qué
pasaría si nos tomamos ahora el caso de
igual a menos 4 de igual a menos 4 lo
que sí sabemos que va a cumplir
si intentamos con -4 debe satisfacer la
ecuación asociada y bueno tú dirás
cuál es la ecuación asociada la ecuación
asociada es justamente en vez de poner
un menor pone son iguales entonces menos
3 p y es pero aquí falta menos 7 debería
ser igual
ap más 9 cuando p es igual a menos 4 y
vamos a ver que esto es cierto menos 3 x
menos 4 -7 es igual a menos 49 esto es
lo que hay que ver menos 3 x menos 4 es
12 menos 7 debería ser igual
a menos que serían nueve menos cuatro
son cinco muy bien y doce menos siete
son cinco que claramente es igual a
cinco entonces esto está muy muy muy muy
bien sin embargo nosotros no teníamos
una igualdad nosotros en realidad
teníamos un menor que entonces si
quitamos todo esto bueno ya vimos que p
si cumple la ecuación asociada pero
vamos a ver que no cumple la desigualdad
porque si tenemos aquí puros menores
puros menores nunca multiplicamos por
nada entonces llegamos a que 5 es menor
que 5 y claramente 5 no es más chico que
el mismo verdad así que menos 4 nos
satisface la desigualdad y eso está muy
bien porque le excluimos del conjunto
solución así que realmente puedes verlo
como un punto frontera